a lawyer for a Connecticut man charged
with killing a Caribbean resort worker
says her client is receiving threats of
violence CBS News has obtained
voicemails with some of the threats
against Scot Hapgood he's expected in
Anguilla court tomorrow in connection
with the death of Kenny Mitchell appcode
says Mitchell attacked him in his hotel
room
Errol Barnett is in San Juan Puerto Rico
on his way to Anguilla
Errol do we know where these threats are
coming from well Anthony it's very
difficult to precisely trace these
threats but hapgoods legal team says
they are concerned for his safety on
that island now Thursday will bring a
preliminary hearing they're in Anguilla
to determine if there's enough evidence
for a trial to begin but Hobgood says
since this happened back in April his
family's lives have changed forever
we're hanging on by a thread to be
honest with you it's been it was a
terrifying incident Scott Hapgood
appeared with his attorney in New York
City Tuesday before his upcoming court
appearance in Anguilla there he's
charged with manslaughter in the death
of resort worker
Kenny Mitchell I my wife my children we
wake up with it we live in it we swim in
it we breathe it every day Hapgood says
while on a vacation with his family back
in April
Mitchell attacked him at knifepoint in
his hotel room in front of his two
daughters the violent encounter ended
with Mitchell dead and Hapgood later
arrested he's been out on bail we were
advised in the context of a security
warning by the police authorities that
the last time in Anguilla that he spends
the better that's because of what his
lawyers call credible threats against
Hapgood they say his family has been
targeted with troubling Facebook posts
and messages plus voicemails some
obtained by CBS News I know exactly
where you live my if I ever see your
punk in Connecticut I swear God in the
jump the Caribbean island is home to
around 17,000 people and many they're
like I ride gums are following the case
closely and want more information
released
to look into it more stronger more
better and let justice prevail because
it doesn't set a good precedent for
angular now a toxicology report shows
that Mitchell had drugs and alcohol in
his system at the time of the alleged
attack now hapgoods lawyers say they
expect prosecutors to tell the judge in
Anguilla tomorrow that they're not yet
ready to formally present their case
Hapgood had requested to appear by video
because of the security concerns and
costs of the constant round-trip travel
Gail that request was denied all right
Errol thank you very much